avec les filles je ne sais pas
il faut encore pas
du tout
à
quand l'une d'entre elles m'a dit
pourquoi
[Musique]
je ne suis pas ces rites que vous croyez
je me dis ne te fait pas d'illusions
en fait tout seul à la maison
et
m
non
moi je reste
coli
avec les filles je ne sais pas
à
tant qu'il faut quand il faut pas
[Applaudissements]
pas les tabous
et chez moi
comme
je ne
et pas
aller chez moi
c'est pour demain il est moche est
fauché
c'est sûr qu'il le doit je ne vois pas
ce qu'il a
avec les filles je ne sais pas
c'est pas tant qu'il faut
il faut pas
[Applaudissements]
marc et le temps
bien par les temps qui courent
aller chez moi
à qui je ne sais pas
toujours le contraire de ce que me
disent à un ami comme quoi en penser les
marcel zanini ce play-boy latin american
moustache américaine chapeau américain
lui tu sais
je
et il faut quand il faut qu aux antilles
y'a pas
avec les filles je ne sais pas
c'est pas tout il faut quand il faut
[Musique]